the is
um
a little bit you know
and keep on wishing
taking nothing left
[Music]
do it
oh yeah
[Music]
hello
[Music]
all right
good food
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now like
good afternoon everybody and those uh
members of the press who have
just arrived we've got fresh boxes on
the screen riser
and on the left little camera pod over
there if you want to just plug in for me
and give me a thumbs up
make sure that you guys have signal uh
for everybody in attendance please
remember to silence your cell phones
that would be a good time thank you
m
thank you
oh no no i am okay
uh
my right
is
where do you see them
how are you
hey
oh
[Music]
uh
oh
are you gonna do it if you really don't
wanna
tell me
oh
you gotta get
tell me
tell me
get down
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it's dark
all right
moving all day
me
me
oh
oh
thank you for being here today today's
event has been set up to adhere to
social distancing guidelines as outlined
by health experts in the state of
pennsylvania the program will begin
shortly
i wish i knew from which way he was
coming
okay
oh
when the story comes out
to make the flies
i don't know that i've even seen that
before
oh
yes
here we are in gettysburg and vice
president president biden is on his way
down
the driveway he's going to speak to us
it's pretty exciting
[Music]
rock and roll
welcome thank you
i appreciate you being here on this
gorgeous day
in a magnificent magnificent setting
do you think about all the lives that
were lost here
please all have a seat
on july 4th 1863
american woke to the remains of
perhaps the most consequential battle
in american soil it took place here on
this ground in gettysburg
three days of violence three days of
carnage
50 000 casualties wounded captured
missing or dead over three days of
fighting
when the sun rose on that independence
day
lee would retreat the war would go on
for nearly two more years
but the back of the confederacy had been
broken
the union would be saved
slavery would be abolished government
by of by and for the people
would not perish from the earth
and freedom would be born anew
in our land there's no more fitting
place
than here today in gettysburg
to talk about the cost of division
on how much it has cost america in the
past
about how much it is costing us now
and about why i believe in this moment
we must come together as a nation
for president lincoln the civil war was
about
the greatest of causes the end of
slavery
widening equality pursuit of justice
the creation of opportunity and the
sanctity
of freedom his words
ever after we hear them in our heads
we know them in our hearts we draw on
them when we seek hope
and hours of darkness
four scoring seven years ago our fathers
brought forth on this continent
a new nation conceived in liberty
and dedicated to the proposition that
all
men are created equal here
on this sacred ground abraham lincoln
reimagined
american self here president of the
united states
spoke of the price of division and the
meaning of sacrifice
he believed in the rescue
redemption and rededication of the union
all this in a time not just
a ferocious division but of widespread
death
structural inequity and fear
of the future and he taught us this
a house divided could not stand
that is a great and timeless truth
today once again we are a house divided
but that my friends can no longer be
we are facing too many crises we have
too much work to do
we have too brighter future to have a
shipwreck
on the shoals of anger and hate
and division as we stand here today a
century and a half later after
gettysburg
we should consider again what can happen
when equal justice is denied when anger
and violence and division
are left unchecked
as i look across america today i'm
concerned
the country is in a dangerous place
our trust in each other is ebbing
hope seems elusive too many americans
see
our public life not as an arena for
mediation of our differences
but rather they see it as an occasion
for total
unrelenting partisan warfare
strutting instead of treating each
other's party as the opposition
we treat them as the enemy this
must end we need to revive the spirit of
bipartisan
in this country the spirit of being able
to work with one another
when i say that and i've been saying it
for two years now i'm accused of being
naive
i'm told maybe that that's the way
things used to work joe
but they can't work that way anymore
well i'm here to tell you they can and
they must
if we're going to get anything done
i'm running as a proud democrat
but i will govern as an american
president
i'll work with democrats and republicans
i work as hard for those who don't
support me
as those who do that's the job of a
president
the duty to care for everyone
refusal of democrats and republicans to
cooperate with one another
is not due to some mysterious force
beyond our control
it's a decision it's a choice we make
and if we can decide not to cooperate we
can decide
to cooperate as well that's the choice
i'll make as president
but there's something bigger going on in
this nation
than just our broken politics
something darker something more
dangerous
i'm not talking about ordinary
differences of opinion
competing future viewpoints give life
and vibrancy to our democracy
now i'm talking about something
different something deeper
too many americans seek not to overcome
our divisions
but to deepen them we must seek
not to build walls but bridges
we must seek not to have our fist
clenched
but our arms open we have to seek not to
tear
each other apart but seek to come
together
you don't have to agree with me on
everything or even on most things
to see that we're experiencing today is
neither good
nor normal i made the decision to run
for president
after charlottesville close your eyes
and remember what you saw neo-nazis
white supremacists and the kkk
coming out of the fields with torches
lighted
veins bulging chanting the same
anti-semitic
bile heard across europe in the 30s
it was hate on the march in the open
in america hate never goes away
it only hides and when it's given oxygen
when it's given an opportunity to spread
when it's treated as normal and
acceptable behavior
we've opened a door in this country that
we must move
quickly to close as president that's
just what i will do
i will send a clear unequivocal message
to the entire nation
there is no place for hate in america
i'll be given it will be given no
license it will be given no
oxygen it will be given no safe harbor
in recent weeks and months the country
has been riled by
instances of excessive police force
heart-wrenching cases of racial
injustice and lives needlessly and
senselessly lost
by peaceful protesters given voice
through calls for justice
by examples of violence and looting and
burning that cannot be
tolerated i believe in law and order
i've never supported to funding the
police but i also believe
injustice is real it's a product of a
history
that goes back 400 years among
black men women and children first were
brought here in chains
i do not believe we have to choose
between law and order
and racial justice in america we can't
have
both this is a nation strong enough to
both
honestly face systemic racism and strong
enough to provide safe streets for our
families and small businesses
that too often bear the brunt of the
saluting and burning
we have no need for armed militias
robbing america streets
we should have no tolerance for
extremist white supremacy groups
menacing our communities if you say
we should trust america's law
enforcement authorities to do the job
as i do then let them do their job
without extremist groups acting as
vigilantes
you say we have no need to face racial
injustice in the country
you haven't opened your eyes to the
truth
in america there have been powerful
voices
for justice in recent weeks and months
george floyd's six-year-old daughter who
i met with
who looked at me and said in her small
child's voice
daddy changed the world
also jacob lake's mother was another
when she said
violence didn't reflect her son and this
nation
needed healing and doc rivers
the basketball coach choking back tears
when he said
we're the ones getting killed we're the
ones getting shot
we've been hung it's amazing why we keep
loving this country
this country does not love us back
i think about that i think about what it
takes for a black person to love america
that is a deep love for this country
that has for
far too long never been recognized
what we need in america's leadership
that seeks to de-escalate tensions
to open lines of communications to bring
us together
to heal to hope as president that's
precisely what i will do
we've paid a high price for allowing the
deep divisions in this country
to impact on how we deal with the
coronavirus
210 000 americans
dead and the numbers climbing
it's estimated that nearly another 210
000 americans could lose their lives by
the end of the year
enough no more
let's just set partisanship aside let's
end the politics and follow the science
wearing a mask wearing a mask is not a
political statement
it's a scientific recommendation
social distancing isn't a political
statement
it's a scientific recommendation
testing tracy the development and all
the approval and distribution of vaccine
isn't a political statement it is a
science-based decision
we can't undo what has been done we
can't go back we can do
so much better we can do better starting
today
we can have a national strategy that
puts politics aside and saves lives
we can have a national strategy that
will make it possible
for our schools and businesses to open
safely
we can have a national strategy that
reflects the true
values of this nation this pandemic is
not a red
state or blue state issue this virus
doesn't care whether you live
where you live what political party you
belong to
it affects us all will take anyone's
life
it's a virus it's not a political weapon
there's another enduring division in
america that we must end
the division in our economic life
that gives opportunity only to the
privileged few
america has to be about mobility it has
to be the kind of country
where an abraham lincoln a child of the
distant frontier
can rise to the highest office in the
land
america has to be about possibilities
the possibility of prosperity
not just for the privileged you but for
the many for all of us
working people and their kids deserve an
opportunity
lincoln knew this he said that the
country had to give people my quota an
open
field and a fair chance an open field
and a fair chance
that's what we're going to do in america
we're going to build
together we fought a civil war
that would secure a union that would
seek to fulfill
the promise of equality for all and by
fits and starts
our better angels have prevailed again
just enough
just enough against our worst impulses
to make a new
and better nation and those
better angels can prevail again now
they must prevail again now
100 years after lincoln spoke at
gettysburg
the vice president lyndon b johnson also
came here and here's what he said
said our nation founded soul and honor
in these fields of gettysburg
we must not lose that soul in dishonor
now on the fields of hate
today we're engaged once again
in the battle for the soul of the nation
the forces of darkness the forces of the
division
the forces of yesterday are pulling us
apart holding us down
and holding us back we must free
ourselves
of all of them mr president
i will embrace hope not fear peace
not violence generosity not
greed and light not darkness
i'll be a president who appeals to the
best of us not the worst
i'll be a president who pushes toward
the future
not one who clings to the past i'm ready
to fight for you and for our nation
every day without exception without
reservation
with a full devoted heart
we cannot and will not allow extremists
and white supremacists
to overturn the america of lincoln and
harriet tubman
and tribute douglas to overturn the
america
that has welcomed immigrants from
distant shores to overturn the america
there's been a haven and a home for
everyone
no matter the background from seneca
falls
to selma to stonewall we're at our best
when the promise america is available to
all
we cannot and we will not allow violence
in the street to threaten the people of
this nation
we cannot and will not walk away from
our obligation
to at long last face the reckoning on
race and racial justice in this country
we cannot and will not continue to be
struck in the partisan politics
that lets us this virus
thrive all the public health of this
nation suffers
we cannot and will not accept
an economic equation that only favors
those who've already got it made
everybody deserves a shot at prosperity
folks thank you duty
duty in history call presidents to
provide for the common good
and i will it won't be easy
it won't be easy our divisions today are
long-standing
economic and racial inequities have
shaped us for generations
but i give you my word i give you
my word if i'm elected president i will
marshal
the ingenuity and good will of this
nation to turn division into unity
and bring us together because i think if
people are looking for that
we can disagree about how we move
forward
we must take the first steps it starts
with how we treat
one another how we talk to one another
how we respect one another
in the second inaugural lincoln said
malice toward none with charity for all
with firmness and the right as god gives
us to see the right
let us strive on to finish
the work we're in to build up the
nation's wounds
bind up the nation's rules now we have
our work
to reunite america to bind up our
nation's move to move past
shadow and suspicion and so we
you and i together you press
on even now after hearing the second
inaugural address
frederick douglass told president
lincoln mr lincoln
that was a sacred effort
we have to be dedicated to our own
sacred effort
the promise of gettysburg and the new
birth of freedom was at hand
i think it's at risk every generation
that's followed gettysburg
has been faced with a moment when it
must answer this question
whether it will allow the sacrifices
made here
to be in vain or be fulfilled
this is our moment to answer this
essential american question
for ourselves and for our time
and my answer is this it cannot be that
after
all this country has been through after
all that america has accomplished
after all the years we have stood as a
beacon of light to the world
it cannot be that here and now in 2020
we'll we will allow the government of
the people by the people and for the
people to perish on this earth
no it cannot and it must not
we have in our hands the ultimate power
the power to vote it's the noblest
instrument ever devised to register our
will
in a peaceable and productive fashion
and so we must
we must vote we will
vote no matter how many obstacles are
thrown in our way because once
america votes america will be heard
lincoln said the nation
is worth fighting for so it was
and so it is together
as one nation under god indivisible
let us join forces to fight the common
fall of injustice and inequality
hate and fear let's conduct ourselves as
americans
who love each other who love our country
who will not
destroy but we'll build
we owe it to the dead who are buried
here at gettysburg
we owe that to the living and the future
generations yet to be born
you and i are part of a covenant a
common story of divisions overcome
and hope renewed if we do our part
if we stand together if we keep faith
with the past
and with each other than the divisions
our time will give way
to the dreams of a brighter better
future
this is our work this is our pledge
this is our mission we can end this era
division
we can end the hate and the fear
we can be what we are at our best the
united
states of america god bless you all can
do this